you're watching the daily climate show
on sky news coming up the government
announces a review of fracking as part
of the response to russia's invasion of
ukraine
and the government is expected to double
hydrogen production targets in the
energy security strategy due out this
week
and the eu pushes for stronger sanctions
that will hit russia's wallet banning
coal imports
dramatic warnings from the u.n on
climate change but what chance of
success if the world's biggest emitter
continues to pump out fossil fuel
emissions
and the ancient practice of silvopasture
making farming climate friendly
hello and welcome to the uk's only daily
climate news show where we track the
changes happening to our world hear from
the people being hit hardest by those
changes and report on the race for
solutions
now the government is expected to double
its target on hydrogen production in the
energy security strategy which we expect
to be published on thursday
hydrogen is considered to have huge
potential as a replacement for fossil
fuels in the future
but in an indication of uncertainty over
energy supplies the government has also
ordered a review into fracking the
controversial process pumps water
chemicals and sand underground at high
pressure to break apart shale rock and
release trapped oil and gas a moratorium
on that process was declared in the uk
in 2019 due to the risk of localized
earth tremors well our business
correspondent paul kelso is with us now
can tell us more so paul to what extent
extent are we getting a sense of the
shape of this big announcement on energy
later in the week
well we've heard quite a lot already
from both the prime minister who's
talked about uh a nuclear revolution and
uh piece by piece from quasi-quatting
the business
secretary about what's going to be in
this long trailed but also slightly
delayed energy strategy the element
we've uh seemed to have bottomed out
today is that there is going to be a
commitment to double
the capacity of hydrogen the target for
hydrogen capacity by 2030 from the
current five gigawatts which is a target
set out just last year in the autumn to
10 gigawatts and significantly that
appears to be split between five
gigawatts of green hydrogen capacity and
five of blue the difference being that
green which is produced by electrolysis
and is produced the power for that
process is provided by renewable sources
of energy so is in effect uh net carbon
neutral zero carbon uh blue hydrogen
requires natural gas and then the carbon
that's emitted in that process
is captured and that makes it low carbon
now green is the one that campaigners
are much more in favor of and it has got
huge potential as you say everything
from replacing natural gas in home
heating perhaps being the answer to
really heavy goods vehicles a
replacement for diesel for vehicles that
are too big to have batteries and indeed
for the really high energy intensive
industries that currently can't see a
solution to high quantities of
electricity or gas much of it which is
produced by gas the government hasn't
confirmed the hydrogen commitment today
but quasi quatong has repeated the five
giga the five gig pledge uh online and
has said the the uk will go further so
it's a fairly clear direction of travel
now all of this of course in the context
of what uh mr kuatang has said in a
speech today is a strategy that is going
to be able to
square the circle of meeting the uk's
net zero commitments while also
providing short-term energy security
it isn't clear
enough already
net zero
is a solution to the global energy
prices
not the cause
expensive
gas
is the problem
cheap clean homegrown energy
is the solution the transition
to clean homegrown energy cannot happen
overnight
it remains the case that there will
continue to be
an ongoing demand for oil and gas
over the coming
decades while we transition
to clean energy
now with that in mind uh today quasi
quietly has also announced this new uh
analysis of the scientific case for
fracking from the british geological
survey uh but that feels like it might
be more political than practical there
will be north sea oil and gas licenses
commitment in this strategy fracking
there's a great deal of pressure from
the tory back benches
to reopen fracking they see it many of
those mps see it as a source of
domestically produced gas of course it
is largely very unpopular certainly
where it's been tried and a moratorium
on fracking was only put in place two
years ago following a previous study
which found it wasn't possible to
predict the severity or indeed
if there could be earthquakes or tremors
as a consequence of hydraulic fracking
for shale gas so unless geology has
changed in the last two years it does
feel like that commitment is so the
government has got something to say to
those back benches who may look at this
energy strategy on thursday and ask what
does it say about fracking the answer
for now it feels to me is it's gone into
even longer grass than it was before
paul thanks very much indeed
well news of further atrocities in
ukraine has pushed the west to impose
fresh sanctions on russia the european
commission is now proposing a total ban
on imports of russian coal a trade worth
billions of pounds of the kremlin and
possibly more to follow sally lockwood
has more from brussels
this is a fifth round of sanctions
imposed on russia by the eu but the
first to touch on energy with a proposal
to ban the import of coal from russia
now this won't be easy it needs to be
passed by all eu 27 members and of
course some are more reliant on coal
imports
than others nearly half
of europe's coal comes from russia but
certainly it offers europe an
opportunity to move away from not only a
reliance on russian fossil fuels but a
reliance on fossil fuels in general and
coal is the biggest emitter of carbon of
all all the fossil fuels so this does
represent a real opportunity
for europe not only to
inflict more economic pain on russia but
also to speed up its own move away from
fossil fuels its own uh to speed up
the move away from a reliance on russian
energy of course oil and gas will be far
more complicated for europe to tackle
they are far more complicated
on oil and gas imports from russia but
coal is achievable in terms of banning
imports
from russia and as i say it does need
passing by all eu 27 members with some
way off that happening a vote does need
to take place but it would represent an
opportunity for europe not only to move
away from fossil fuels but to increase
its use of renewables and also it will
be an important step forward towards
reaching its target of being carbon
neutral by 2050.
let's get some of the day's other
climate news now and british drivers
bought more electric vehicles in march
alone than in the whole of 2019. the
society of motor manufacturers and
traders reported 39
315 new battery electric vehicles
registered in march compared to 37 850
for the whole of 2019. the society says
with fuel prices at record highs it
makes sense for families to switch to a
greener vehicle
swiss startup kleinworks has raised
almost 500 million pounds in funding to
scale up its technology which extracts
carbon dioxide directly from the air it
currently operates the world's largest
direct air capture plant in iceland
where trapped co2 is injected deep
underground and stored permanently
it comes as the intergovernmental panel
on climate change confirmed carbon
dioxide removal technology will be
essential for limiting global warming to
1.5 degrees
and the cost of living crisis is being
felt in many places as russia's war in
ukraine disrupts supply chains around
the world in peru
protests have been raging since last
week over a rapid surge in prices for
food fuel and fertilizer peru's
government says at least four people
have been killed amid violent clashes
between protesters and police
now this week's climate report from the
un makes for difficult reading for world
leaders carbon emissions must peak by
2025 said the world's leading climate
scientists before falling steeply by
2030. well targets seem out of reach
already but especially so when china the
world's biggest emitter doesn't plan to
slow its heavy consumption of coal
anytime soon as our beijing
correspondent tom cheshire explains
this u.n report didn't name any one
country but china obviously looms large
it is the world's biggest polluter
although it does sometimes like to
qualify that by saying you should look
at historical emissions or emissions per
capita even on those measures though
these days actually china has pulled
ahead of europe in terms of emissions
per capita even if it's still the us
who's in number one and in terms of
historical emissions despite really only
recently going through an industrial
revolution catching up with the rest of
the world it's already the second
biggest historical emitter and whatever
the way you look at it china has an
outsized role because of its role as the
biggest polluter both positive and
negative when it comes to this report
there are issues really of timing and
trajectory this yearn report called for
emissions to peak by 2025 but china's
plan is to peak them only by 2030. the
other issue is trajectory how does it
gets that emissions peak does it slowly
build up to that 20 30 peak or does it
add capacity uh adding a lot more carbon
into the air and then wind it down from
2030 the problem is it looks like at the
moment china is going for the lasso
option adding cold capacity in
particular it had a series of energy
shocks last year and as a result it's
moved to secure its coal supply it's
been commissioning new coal power
stations president xi jing ping at a
recent political session here in beijing
so the coal would be a mainstay of the
energy mix so it seems like china really
has invested significant political
capital and coming up with those
original targets has invested a huge
amount
in renewable energy more than any other
country on the world but in terms of
budgeting those targets i don't think
that's likely to happen no matter how
stark the warnings in this un report
have been
[Music]
monday's u.n climate report was as much
about solutions as problems and the
natural world has a huge role to play
research suggests that silvopasture
that's integrating trees and pasture
into a single system for raising
livestock helps counteract methane
emissions from animals and sequesters
carbon
we've been to somerset where one farmer
has been adapting the ancient method
i've have an obsession with soil and the
multitude of benefits that good soil
management can bring to
farming and the landscape and
sort of a greater society
silver pasture is a mixture of um trees
in in
planted in a pasture and the idea is
that uh they bring a benefit to the
livestock which graze for pasture and
they can live under the trees and
amongst the trees
[Music]
soil is is the basis of life in terms of
carbon is
the largest pool of carbon there is
so if we
don't
destroy this pool
so we don't lose the carbon into the
atmosphere
carbon will be
there to sustain life and that's what
silver pasture is about it's about
bringing trees
to improve ecosystem services and
soil structure because the roots and the
plants stabilize the soil
[Music]
when i first started farming here
i've been here since 1991 we spent years
and years uh just conventionally farming
and all our soil used to move quite
quickly downhill when it rained the
houses used to flood every single time
we had you know an inch and a half of
the lane
now we don't uh have any flooding all
the water that lands on this landscape
so straight in
oh boys
uh this farm used to be droughty so in
the summer if we had a if we had too
much sunshine and and long spells were
out in the rain the wheat would actually
stop growing and sometimes it would die
early and we'd get yield losses we don't
get that anymore but increased carbon
levels increases the ability of soil to
hold water
it's difficult um
when
when the climate is changing farmers
know what they're doing they know
what to cultivate where but i think the
challenge is
reacting to change
and and change is happening very quickly
do stay with us coming up i'll be joined
by chief executive of the climate group
helen clarkson and george monbiot
columnist and environmental activists
and we'll be discussing hydrogen
fracking and more on the un's big
climate report
[Music]
i'm inzamam rasheed and i'm sky's north
of england correspondent telling stories
from this culturally rich region i call
home
it's going to become very similar to
other places and lose its unique
qualities it's steeped in history
[Music]
if the taliban found your family what
would happen i think they're just going
to straight away execute them
there are issues of racism in all levels
of cricket i was in the balcony a couple
of times i was nearly gone
football is a joy to watch and when
people are disappointed you can feel the
hate
[Music]
i just felt physically safe so i was
like that that's really in my system
we take you to the heart of the stories
that shape our world
even before the pandemic gps were
pleading for help government expects
more face-to-face contact with patients
in
return men they want to force you doing
something which you don't want to do
just because you're homeless and you're
looking for a warm place to sleep
we give a voice to communities often
unheard and unserved from a region with
a distinct history and global impact
[Music]
[Music]
hello and welcome back to the daily
climate show on sky news i'm getting
straight to discussing the climate
issues of the day now with chief
executive of the climate group helen
clarkson and george monbiot guardian
columnist and long-time climate activist
so good evening to both of you nice to
see you both
so the government is preparing to
publish its energy security strategy on
thursday we're told and we're hearing
very different things today news of an
increase in hydrogen production but also
a review into the controversial gas
extraction process fracking well the
business and energy secretary quasi
quatern has said that in the light of
putin's criminal invasion of ukraine
it's absolutely right that we explore
all possible domestic energy sources so
let's talk about some of them helen
clarkson to you first of all so we're
told then that the government is
expected to double its target for
hydrogen production as part of this
energy security strategy the suggestion
being that that would be made up of 50
of green hydrogen which is produced
using renewable energy and 50 blue
hydrogen which uses fossil fuels to
produce it but then the carbon emitted
in that process would be then captured
just to explain it all so do you welcome
that that target if that does turn out
to be what's announced
i think what's very frustrating is what
i'm seeing in a lot of
uh what we're hearing so far about the
energy strategy what we've heard from
governments over recent weeks is a lot
of
sort of techno-optimism there's
something bigger and better coming on
the horizon just weights and a lot of
pushing this out a few years we do need
to invest in hydrogen green hydrogen is
going to be part of the future not for
the applications that we've been hearing
about it's much more about industrial
processes
steel as a chemical feedstock fertilizer
it's not really you know going to be
very useful in that kind of domestic
front and so yes we need to invest in
green hydrogen it makes much more sense
to expand the markets you know where
you've got a big solar resource and you
can you know use it in off-peak time so
think about the sahara australia you
know that's where we need to be
developing green hydrogen it does not
make sense to sort of put all our eggs
in these
sort of strange baskets which are very
much about pushing this into the future
when we have solutions right here in
front of us now we have
we could be doing much more wind much
more on solar
and much much more on energy efficiency
and i think it's a it's a strange
strategy to always be looking for sort
of a new technology when we've got
plenty of technologies that really
urgently need to go to scale
george what do you think because i mean
helen
may be talking about part of the picture
we may have loads more announcements on
renewables as well might and we and the
future matters too doesn't it i mean
quasi quattang has called hydrogen a
home grown super fuel i mean worth
investing in what do you think
well yeah we do need investment in
hydrogen but the whole idea that we
could do half of this or so with
so-called blue hydrogen in other words
made from fossil fuels well that locks
us into future fossil fuel use and if
there's one thing we know
is that we can't afford to allow
ourselves to be locked into future
fossil fuel use
and so yeah you know green hydrogen
great made from renewables as helen says
better in some places than others
there's other routes too you could make
it for instance using
high-temperature gas-cooled nuclear
reactors which reach a sufficient
temperature to crack water directly
without the use of electrolysis and that
could be very efficient in the future
potentially very cheap but helen is also
right to say you know we've got a whole
lot of stuff
right now which we need to be doing like
insulating homes i mean it's crazy we
had a a program for insulating homes for
greening people's homes that was cut
dead by the government and we saw loft
insulation cavity wall insulation
everything fall off a cliff with the
result that we've got far higher
emissions than we should have and people
are in fuel poverty it's crazy okay
sorry to cut you off you've got so much
to get in one of the other things that
some people will say was cut off as well
was fracking we're now told there's
going to be a review into it partly in
the light of the ukraine crisis um that
the government is talking about needing
all options and and really helen there
are issues of national security as well
as affordability uh to be considered as
well is fracking one of the ways through
those those different uh
obstacles
fracking should not even be part of this
conversation look the the if even if you
completely put aside the massive climate
catastrophe rephrase which the ipcc and
the ie8 very clear no new fossil fuels
it's at least 10 years till you get any
gas from fracking and it would meet a
tiny tiny bit of the uk energy demand
and our price is not set by what we
produce in the uk it's set in global
markets so it doesn't mean any of the
tests that you would want it doesn't
deal with immediate issues it's not
going to bring the price down and it's
just a crazy thing to be bringing back
and then bring back in climate change
bring back in huge environmental things
and then just pragmatically i mean who
is going to finance fracking is not
commercial you know the planning process
is going to take him out a certain
amount of time you can then imagine
protests you know some of us old enough
to remember green and common i just
think this is just pragmatically it
makes no sense and shouldn't be even on
the table at this point and yet george
monbiot some people say you do still
need some fossil fuels as part of a
managed transition to a greener energy
future
yeah so the whole story is we need
fossil fuels as a bridge to get us out
of fossil fuels sorry no if you want to
get out of fossil fuels you get out of
fossil fuels and as the recent ipcc
report says we've got all the
technologies right there at our
fingertips the more we invest in fossil
fuels the less likely we are to get out
of them and in fact those fossil fuel
investments if we're going to take
climate breakdown seriously will be
stranded assets we're going to have
trillions and trillions of dollars worth
of fossil fuel investments which we can
no longer use that doesn't make economic
sense let alone environmental sense so
if you want to get out of fossil fuels
it's like getting off addiction you just
got to start today and you've got to
start by
instantly starting to shut down our
fossil fuel capacity and build up our
low carbon capacity instead and there's
a recent report showing that if we're
going to do our part in the uk we've got
to stop all fossil fuel production by
2034. well yes and the ipcc's report
yesterday helen highlighted the fact
that we need to
emissions need to stop rising before
2025. and yet you look at countries like
china we covered this earlier in the
programme
they are the world's biggest emitter
they are going to carry on expanding
their oil production until 2030. so is
it almost irrelevant when the smaller
emitting countries are making changes
when you've got this big country
basically breaking that rule that the
ipcc says should be set
well first of all we've got to nix the
idea that we're a small emitting country
we are a major emitter and every
molecule of carbon in the atmosphere
makes a difference and so yeah there's
there's a lot of work to do india china
and others have got goals further out
into the future and i think if countries
like the uk want to influence those
countries we've got to be shown to doing
our part it's okay it's it just makes no
logical sense to say well we've got to
wait for them okay we've all got to do
everything we can as soon as possible
i'm cutting off because i've only got a
few seconds to give george a quick word
on this as well george
yeah
at the moment we've got a government
which since the cop 26 climate summit
has already licensed one new oil and gas
field it intends to license six more in
the near future now that is a government
which cannot point the finger at anyone
else for not playing their part
okay uh the government here would say
it's all part of the managed process
they've got ambitious targets and they
aim to meet them but um we can discuss
that another day i thought you might
shake your head okay george monvio helen
clarkson thanks both very much indeed
well that's all for today but joining me
on the show tomorrow are the former
energy secretary amber rad and majid
majid a former mayor of sheffield and
mep
coming up next trevor phillips will be
looking for common ground between two
guests on different sides of a
controversial issue and tonight's topic
should the west do more to help ukraine
fight on that's up next on common ground
but from me thanks for watching i'll see
you next time
[Music]
you